a lot of people think they're wasting
their time working at their job or doing
some repetitive tasks because they see
people on Instagram they see me saying
you need to do high leverage activities
and you do the thing is is how do you
build leverage you build leverage by
having stair step of activities that
build on the past effort so for example
if you wanted to get into Finance you
want to be an investment banker you want
to do private Equity if you can't do
arithmetic it's going to be really tough
to be in private Equity but when you're
doing your math problems when you're 10
years old you're not thinking like man
this is such low leverage it is low
leverage but it's building to the next
thing that will give you more leverage
people conflate sequence they think what
they're doing is not getting them
leveraged because it's not getting them
leveraged today but it is building the
fulcrum that they're going to be able to
crank leverage on later on in their
career